bonjour vous merci d'être en direct avec
nous pour justement parler de cette
décision
cela fait des années que l'arabie
saoudite a une politique de répression
c'est la troisième fois qu'elle est
pointé du doigt que pourrait-il arriver
à ryad à l'issue de cette examinations
selon vous bonjour battu d'abord il ya
il faut rappeler que certainement c'est
vrai que l'arabie saoudite et les i
toujours citer parmi ce genre de rapport
au niveau de l'onu
c'est par rapport à un retard au niveau
de matières déni des droits de l'homme
ça avec l'avènement du prince héritier
mohammed bin salman en 2010 est
certainement il a annoncé qu'il y aura
des réformes dans ce genre de dossier il
a commencé par des réformes concernant
les droits les droits de femmes et
certains droits on va le peut dire des
droits qu'on peut qualifier de droit et
économique voire une ouverture vers
cette question de droit de droits de
l'homme maintenant c'est un chemin qui
étrenneront et effectivement on va dire
l'assassinât du journaliste jamal
khashoggi a beaucoup impacter ce
processus et la même impact l image de
l'arabie de l'arabie saoudite dans ce
don dans ce dossier donc effectivement
il ya sept cette partie on peut dire de
l'analyse par rapport à une réalité mais
il ya aussi une autre partie de
l'analyse qui est lié à un peu ce qu'on
peut appeler une façon de faire une
pression à l'arabie saoudite à travers
ce genre de deux dossiers c'est à dire
qu'il ya des pays qui ont des vous
parler de pression en arabie saoudite il
ya énormément à faire il ya la vieille
le danemark par de tortures détentions
arbitraires disparitions forcées ya
aussi les la discrimination entre hommes
et femmes
quelle est la réaction justement de
l'arabie saoudite qui essayent petit à
petit de faire des campagnes pour un
petit peu changer l image du pays mais
disons qu'ils les démons du passé
ressurgissent
pas tout à fait l'arabie saoudite est la
même mais un grand projet pour tourner
cette page en concernant l'aller les
droits des droits de l'homme et surtout
après l'assassinât de jamal khashoggi un
grand effort au niveau de la matière de
la communication des changements de
certains de certains loi ça a déjà
commencé
il ya un débat sur la question de la
peine
moore et à la question aussi la débat
sur l'utilisation ou l'affection à la
loi à la loi islamique c'est-à-dire la
charia dans la justice saoudienne en
plus que ça il ya tout à fait à mener un
effort en matière d'économie et de
politique donc ce qui fait la vision
2030 qui a essayé de mettre en quelque
sorte une diversification de l'économie
de l'arabie saoudite des grands des
grands projets l'arabie saoudite se
prépare également pour l'organisation du
sommet de g20 le mois le mois de
novembre sont autant de pas qui vise à
en quelque sorte le fait de changer 7 7
7 cette image maintenant il ya des
rivaux régionaux dont pour l'arabie
saoudite eut précises comme le cas de le
qatar la turquie au même l'iran qui
essaye de mettre la pression au niveau
international sur cette partie sur sa la
question de droit de lang pour mettre la
pression sur l'arabie saoudite il ya un
certain moment la turquie même elle a
demandé des sanctions contre contre
l'arabie saoudite des pays dont
l'occident comme les etats unis ou même
d'autres pays européens n'ont pas
intérêt à faire des sanctions sur
l'arabie saoudite parce qu'elles ont des
intérêts géopolitiques et économiques
liés à la question du pétrole avec avec
l'arabie donc ce qui fait que là c'est
vrai qu'il ya en réalité il ya un gros
dossiers de droit de droits de l'homme
mais en fin de compte il ya une
utilisation une politique de ce dossier
contre l'arabie saoudite pour soi mettre
une pression soit également
on va dire limiter le rôle de l'arabie
saoudite dont la région et surtout dans
le monde arabo musulman
ce pays est très proche des etats-unis
avec qui pourtant une partage presque
aucune valeur est ce que les bonnes
relations avec les états unis pourrait
jouer en leur faveur pour obtenir un
siège à l'onu
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de valeurs
qui sont partagés au niveau 1 au niveau
économique le même la personnalité a
beaucoup apprécié le prince héritier
mois mettre des mois m salman il l'a
même soutenu après laffaire de jamal
khashoggi certainement les états unis
israël ont un intérêt avec l'arabie
saoudite en ce qui concerne la sécurité
de la région le fait de mettre en une
campagne contre contre l'iran le pétrole
qu'on plus l'arabie saoudite
investissent dans des grandes
l'entreprise américaine récemment le
fonds souverain de l'arabie saoudite à
injecter de l'argent dans facebook dans
tesla dans starbucks dans autant
d'entreprises aux états unis donc ce qui
fait que les intérêts économiques sont
une grande priorité pour les américains
par rapport à une situation on peut dire
de droite l'homme ou bien de démocratie
sachant bien que il ya une pression même
au niveau interne sur le principe je me
permets de vous interrompre hui seront
manque de temps mais j'ai une dernière
question à vous poser
le royaume wahhabite est ce qu'on vous
avait espoir finalement qu'il change
puisque c'est quand même l'adn du pays
qui qui étend qui est en jeu c'est c'est
la troisième fois que le pays est quand
même pointé du doigt et pourtant les
choses ne sens pas énormément à quelques
changements mais est ce qu on a espoir
que finalement par exemple l'achat
gayral soient mises de côté ou que les
femmes soient et les mêmes droits que
les hommes dans le pays
je crois que par rapport à l'expérience
internationale ce genre de changement
vient de l'inter ne viennent pas par une
pression externe
c'est à dire là maintenant il ya une
nouvelle génération d'hommes et de
femmes saoudiennes qui veulent un
changement qui veulent plus d'ouverture
à par rapport à cette question de droit
et je crois que y aura une réaction ça
va pas être vraiment le parfait on peut
pas avoir un royaume à l'égard de
l'espagne de l'angleterre
mais on peut avoir un royaume qui est
semi autoritaire dans cette danse est à
dans cette région du fait qu'il doit
s'adapter par rapport aux impératifs de
2,2 le de siècle du 20e siècle est
également de certaines pressions qui
fait part par certains pays au niveau
international précisément l'occident
c'est à dire l'occident américain et
l'occident hors pair elle fait la merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes consultant
géopolitique et spécialiste du monde
arabe